the add eventlistener method attaches an
event handler to the specified element
without overwriting existing event
handlers so you can add many event
handlers to one element so here's the
syntax you're gonna put the element
you're trying to access and then add
event listener and then you're gonna
pass in the event and this is the type
of event like click or Mouse down and
then you're gonna pass in the function
and then the use capture this is a
boolean value specifying whether to use
event bubbling or event capturing this
is optional and I'll explain this in a
little bit so we already have this HTML
codes displaying over here and we've
already selected all of our elements so
what I'm gonna do is create an event
listener so here we're catching an event
listener to the paragraph that's this
first paragraph up here and it's gonna
be a click so on click we're gonna run
this function so I'm just gonna set the
background of my div to light blue which
already is right now but if we reset
everything it will go back to this coral
so now if I click the words it changes
to light blue now this actually does the
same thing that this other that I'll
click would do so when you use add event
listener and passing click for the event
you could also do it like this you could
set unclick equal to this function here
however there are some bad things about
using on click with onclick you may have
only one event assigned at a time so if
you sign another event to on click it
will overwrite the first event
you also can't set the use capture so
generally you want to use an event
listener
however I'll click does work in all
browsers and add event listener does not
work in older versions of Internet
Explorer before version 9 before version
9 you've used attach event instead of an
event listener okay instead of declaring
our entire function in here we can
actually just pass a function reference
change text and then it will call that
function then here it's been just going
to set the text content of paragraph 2
to some other words so if I
here you can see that two things just
happened the color change - light blue
and this text down here changed with
onclick only this text would change
because it would have overwritten the
changing the background color but with
an event listener both things can happen
okay this right here is an example of
something besides click before we were
using the click event now we're using
the mouse over event so if I bring the
mouse over the first div and we see it
changes to dark khaki for div 2 now I'm
going to talk about that use capture
parameter this changes the order that
things happen end so we have an event on
the first paragraph and then we have an
event on the first div so the my P and
my div so when I'm clicking the
paragraph I'm also clicking the div at
the same time so the last parameter is
is how it is determined which event to
run first so let's add the last
parameter here remember you don't need
it because it defaults to false so the
first event listener is going to run the
change text function the second event
the listeners we're going to run the
change text to function so we have to
create that function so here's change
text to change text and change text to
are both going to change the second
paragraph text content and this one is
going to just take the text content and
add the real answer on to the end and
we're gonna make a slight modification
to change text 1 now both change text
and change text 2 we're going to take
the text content that's already there
and then append new text and this will
help us see what order the functions are
executed in if I click the paragraph 1
and the div at the same time you can see
first it's appending the real answer and
then it's appending according to a
Cornell publication the answer is 700
pounds so if this last parameter is set
to true the outermost elements event
handled first and then the inner however
if this is set to false the innermost
elements event is handled first and then
the outer so let's see an example of
that and now here we can see first it
appends according to cornell publication
the answer 700 pounds and then it
appends the real answer
so again when to event listeners are
attached to two different elements but
they're gonna run at the same time the
last parameter tells what order to run
them in okay the last thing i wanna talk
about is remove event listener with the
remove event listener it's pretty
self-explanatory just removes an event
listener that you previously added you
just have to make sure that the
parameters that you pass in are exactly
the same so it removes the exact one you
can only remove an event listener where
you are calling a function by a name
here if you actually put in the function
like this into the event listener then
removing it won't work okay well thanks
for watching my name is beau Carnes
don't forget to subscribe and remember
use your code for good